كنت اتحدث عما صرح به صباح هذا اليوم
نتنياهو في مستهل الجلسه الاسبوعيه
للحكومه بدا هذه الجلسه واستهل بقراءه ما
قال انها رساله من عشرات العائلات لضحايا
وجنود اي قتلوا في المعارك في غزه هكذا
قال بانه تلقى رساله صباح هذا اليوم من
عشرات العائلات وطلبت منه
ان يواصل القتال وعدم التوقف في منتصف
الطريق وفقا
لتعبيره قرا هذه الرساله على مسامع
الوزراء وقال لهم بان عائلات الجنود القتل
واضح ما الذي يجري نجوان من
حولك
نعم
قصف قوي جدا لكن يرافقه ايضا
رشاشات اشتباكات برشاشات ثقيله من موقع
قريب منا ينطلق هذا القصف المتواصل كما
تسمعون هل هناك داعي لاستهداف مدفعي
متواصل هذه الاماكن
القريبه لا القذف ينطلق من المواقع
القريبه
منا ط ان كان هناك ربما مكان يمكنك
الاحتماء نعطيك ربما الوقت نجوان من اجل
سلامتك يعني نحن بخير القصف ينطلق من
المواقع القريبه من الموقع الذي نتواجد
فيه لكنه بطبيعه الحال يستهدف مواقع قريبه
محاذ للحدود داخل قطاع غزه لكن الاصوات
عنيفه جدا
يعني اذا كنا نحن غنوى نرتعب من هذه
الاصوات فكيف هو الحال بمن يعيش تحت هذا
القصف مده
يوما بالفعل الاصوات مرعبه سواء كانت
لانطلاق المدفعيه او للانفجارات التي
تحدثها مباشره بعد
القصف المتواصل هذا القصف متواصل منذ
ساعات الصباح منذ ايام على مواقع بعينها
سواء كان في هذه المناطق الشرقيه في حي
الشجاعيه في مخيم جباليا في جحر الديك هذه
المناطق التي نرصدها من هذا الموقع لكن
القصف متواصل على مواقع كثيره اخرى في
داخل غزه صباح اليوم تواجدنا في المناطق
الشماليه وراينا ان قوات الجيش تواصل
القصف حتى في منطقه بيت حانون المحاذيه
تماما للحدود الشماليه والتي كانت قد قصفت
الجزء الاكبر منها مع بدايه هذه الحرب
بالقصف الجوي قبل لحتى البدء بالعمليه
البريه في ال 26 من شهر اكتوبر ال الماضي
ولكن مع ذلك يتواصل القصف على مواقع معينه
سواء كان في منطقه بيت حنون او بيت لاهيه
ولكن تحديدا ايضا في منطقه جباليا الى
الجنوب قليلا من بيت لاهيه وبيت حنون هناك
قصف مدفعي متواصل لكن ايضا يرافقه قصف من
الجو سواء كان بالطائرات الحربيه او
بالمروحيات العسكريه من طراز الاباتشي
طيله الوقت هناك تحليق لهذا النوع من من
مروحيات بالاضافه ايضا الى المسيرات
العسكريه التي ترصد اي تحرك في في الحدود
ولكن ايضا في داخل قطاع غزه وهذا يعني بان
المقاومه في هذه المناطق متواصله من قبل
مقاتلي القسام وباقي الفصائل الفلسطينيه
حتى في المناطق الشماليه ولكن لكن ايضا
وباعتراف من الجيش و باعتراف كبار قاده
الجيش الاسرائيلي المقاومه شرسه جدا في
المناطق ايضا الجنوبيه سواء كان في خان
يونس وايضا في المناطق الشرقيه في
الشجاعيه وهي ربما تعرقل وتؤخر كل الخطط
العسكريه والعمليات التي كان قد وضعها
الجيش في بدايه التوغل البري عندما وضع
تصورا افاد به به بان هذه المعارك ستحسم
في وقت اقصى في وقت اقل وبعد الانتهاء من
السيطره بالكامل على المناطق الشماليه
فانه سيتقدم اكثر الى الجنوب لكن من
الواضح انه حتى بعد 72 يوما على هذه الحرب
على هذه المعارك الضاريه من القصف الجوي
والمدفعي ومن البحر ايضا الا انه لم يتم
سيطرته على المناطق الشماليه ويجد يجد
صعوبه بالغه ايضا بالتقدم نحو المناطق
الجنوبيه وهذا ما يتحدث عنه اكثر ربما هذا
كان واضحا منذ البدايه واحد الكتاب في
صحيفه دعوت احرونوت كتب يوم امس ربما هذا
كان واضحا للقياده العسكريه منذ اليوم
الاول لكنهم لم يستطيعوا مخالفه الاهداف
التي وضعتها القياده السياسيه من تحديد
لاهداف فضفاضه جدا اهداف عامه جدا تحدثت
عن القضاء كليا على حركه حماس دون معرفه
ماذا يعني ذلك وكيف سيتم ذلك وما هي
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه لتحقيق ذلك ومن
الواضح بان بالايام الاخيره الماضيه بدا
يدلي المحللون العسكريون والامني الذين
كانوا في بدايه هذه الحرب يتسترون على مثل
هذه الامور وعلى مثل مناقشه هذه القضايا
باتوا اليوم يتحدثون عنها باعلان اسرائيل
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا يتمكن حتى حتى هذه
اللحظه من السيطره على اي من المواقع ولا
يستطيع تحقيق اي من الاهداف التي وضعتها
وضعها مجلس الحرب لهذه الحرب